[Music]
[Applause]
Reggie Miller will be on the call
tonight's Eastern Conference Finals game
one Heats Celtics tip-off and Boston
will be 8 30 Eastern on TNT we'll get to
that coming up who was skinnier at age
19. you
Kevin Durant or Victor one by Yama
yeah
wow uh I'll rank up in this order I'll
go
I'll go Victor one
me too KD 3.
I was pretty I was pretty loud I think I
was 170
two or three
six six six seven you're six seven one
seventy three ish when the Pacers
selected me in 87. all right the
expectations for Victor one by Emma
should be what his first year in San
Antonio
well look if they're putting the same
expectations they put on LeBron James
who was anointed The Chosen One by
himself and by Sports Illustrated rookie
of the year and the second coming look
I've seen all the the same highlights
and uh that you have and this young man
looks like he has everything it takes to
be the next great one so I think
everything short of a rookie of the year
um and I think he's going to the perfect
franchise if again I think San Antonio
will make the smart call and draft him
number one
you're going to a system where they're
known to highlight the Big Man David
Robinson obviously Tim Duncan and you're
next in line
um Popovich is one of the greatest NBA
coaches we've seen I think they'll mold
him in that right direction so
everything's short of a rookie of the
year I think should be on his play but
Popovich and like evolving into today's
NBA he's never really embraced the three
um doesn't seem like it's a you know
wide open fun type of basketball
um but I wonder with him with when by
Yama
do you let him go is he going to be a
featured guy because I mean Pop's pretty
conservative
I think he was conservative I gotta
disagree with you a little bit they
played in Old School type game when
David Robinson was there okay and they
would look they went through different
times so it was David Robinson
then they they shifted the offense for
Tim Duncan and when Tim Duncan started
to get a little bit older it was Tony
Parker and Manu Ginobili so they did
kind of switch to the threes in wide
open more space the passing
um and pop has evolved with the times it
depends on who's going to surround
um Victor as well what other players
they got a very young team
um but again I think pop is the right
man if you want to learn what the NBA is
all about I think pop is is the right
answer here he's 74. I know
age ain't nothing but a number I mean oh
no I but but the thing is is I wonder if
they didn't win this Lottery
is pop gonna you know does he coach
longer or or you know is he gonna maybe
one or two more years but now with
Victor Juan bioma you know you're going
to want to stay a little bit longer I
think but let's not forget pop is coming
off a gold medal as well coaching on
these younger players and all that so
it's not like he's out of touch he just
won a gold medal in the recent Olympics
and probably he's going to do it again
in France coming up so
I mean we I don't want to focus in on
his age I focus in on what
he has done for the game and his ability
to coach these younger players yeah and
that's fair I I just wonder you know the
passion to continue to coach when you
get to be 74 and is it do you look and
say do I I guarantee you this he woke up
this this morning still in 44.
how does LeBron feel today waking up
after what happened last night
well it's difficult because
and you have seen and called a lot of
playoff games when you get an
opportunity and you're that close to
winning a road playoff game you have to
get those games again they put
themselves in the hole down 21 as early
as the third quarter and they scratched
and clawed their way to get back and
they had opportunities LeBron misses 204
free throws down the stretch he misses a
three up top to tie it and then he gets
stripped in the end
um so if you're LeBron you're not
feeling great but you're also optimistic
we were this close to getting game one
uh we have another opportunity to you
know steal home court advantage in game
two they made some minor adjustments in
terms of their coverage on jokic putting
uh Ruby on him as opposed to Anthony
Davis Anthony Davis became the Roamer
and the rim protector which helped
um so let's see if that factors in in
game two but I wonder when we talked to
Scott Hastings in the first hour the
Nuggets broadcaster and he said if I was
going to change up the defense and bring
in rui hachimura I would have done that
to start game two because then they have
to adjust in the game as opposed to now
you've got 48 hours to prepare for that
defensive strategy by the Lakers
and again that worked for a quarter and
a half it was successful but don't think
that coach Malone and the nuggets are
not going to adapt and adjust and yoke
is just not going to adjust to to rui
one thing that Jeff Van Gundy pointed
out
and he's correct I didn't like Aaron
Gordon being at the hash mark because
uh Anthony Davis was guarding him and he
could be that rim protector you've got
to keep Anthony Davis out of the paint
to allow jokic to go to work on rui he
he was bringing his man too close to him
if Gordon is out Anthony Davis is not
there and you've got to trust your jump
shot if you're Anthony Gordon I was
telling people to start the show a lot
of times we'll watch basketball but we
watch highlights it's rare when we sit
down and watch a game and maybe a game
that may not have excitement written all
over because Joker is not exciting he's
just a brilliant basketball player but
now because the Lakers are in this
you're watching a full game so now you
get to see
just how how he does it because he's not
going to make the highlights on
SportsCenter every night you know be a
Chris bounce pass or maybe you know nice
little uh you know three-pointer now
you're watching and you're going damn
that's how he does it and there's
certain players though Reds that you
have to watch him in a game as opposed
to you're watching a highlight and
you're going God that guy's unbelievable
Kawhi Leonard's like that for me when
Kawhi was Kauai
he didn't make the highlights because
it'd be a you know a nice 15-foot you
know foul line extended jumper at the
end of the game or something The Joker
is kind of forcing people to watch
exactly how he does what he does
I would also throw probably Jimmy Butler
in there there too yeah okay yeah I see
it and then when you watch a full 48
minute game of the Joker Kawaii Jimmy
Butler you learn to appreciate it it's
Precision basketball when you're
watching
um Nicola because
the best compliment that he's getting is
during live action and if you're looking
at Twitter or reading things like that
you see other NBA players commenting
like this is unbelievable like dejante
Murray is saying how is this this dude
not a three-time MVP
when your peers are commenting how great
you are playing and and the effect that
you're having on the game
um you're right sometimes it can be
boring people are used to dunks and the
fancy passes and you know jumping out of
the gym you're not going to get that
with jokic what you're going to get is
proper footwork boxing out persisting
passioning
um making free throws uh rebounding in
space and great teamwork and to me
that's coaches can appreciate that and
your teammates can appreciate that
there's a Tim Duncan feel to his game oh
yeah I mean just kind of
um structured not exciting but extremely
efficient and you know Tim a better
Defender you'll get you better passer
but you know sort of that footwork and
uh you know kind of systematic torture
that they gave you you look up and you
go wait those are the numbers that he
had and there are some guys where you go
wait he only had like 21 points and
there are other guys who have 30 and you
go how did he have 30.
well and he again you go back to the
guys that Tim Duncan had to go against
Kevin Garnett shaking his head the best
I've ever played against Shaquille
O'Neal who got locked horns a lot with
those Lakers Spurs moments shaking his
head
Tim Duncan and it's funny because we we
you know we started off this segment
talking about Victor
if I'm pop and I'm bringing back Tim
Duncan hey every practice every film
session
come on back because I want you to teach
this young man everything that's in your
brain
we're talking to Reggie Miller be on the
call tonight it's game one in Boston at
8 30 Eastern on TNT I'm wondering how
the heat steel this game given that the
Celtics just went through what they went
through with the 76ers and I saw where
the ESPN analytics said Miami had a
three percent chance to win this series
so you're doing the game how does Miami
steal this
uh Jimmy Butler has to play like he
played against Milwaukee in Milwaukee he
was great to superb he was fantastic he
absolutely carried them and that's when
Tyler hero went down in that game one
and he just put the heat on his back and
and they just wrote him to you know to
the finish line
he was good against New York but other
guys stepped up I'm not telling him he
has to have a historic 56 Point night
like he did against Milwaukee but if he
plays like that in streus Gabe Vincent
Caleb Martin Duncan Robinson they
knocked down threes like they did in New
York because those role players were
great if Jimmy Butler is great and those
role players played like they played in
that Knicks series yes they can still
game one and they can also win the steer
this series the problem is you know what
you're gonna get with the Celtics
they've got the best defense and offense
remaining of all the four playoff teams
um they've got great depth Off the Bench
and they can play Big with Robert
Williams and Al Horford or they can play
small bringing in Derek white they got
the Sixth Man of the Year Malcolm
Brogden and the heat don't have those
bodies hero gone Victor oladip people
gone so these other guys have to step up
they've got to make threes which they
weren't great during the regular season
but they've been very good in the
playoffs can they continue to make
threes and they've got to turn over
Boston if they can turn over Boston
which they've done all playoff series in
their games and get off in transition
before Boston can set their defense they
have a shot the best opening is in
Milwaukee Philly or Phoenix
wow wow
hello Katie Booker and the and you got
the Valley of the Sun he
if you're a coach that's very attractive
but Milwaukee you've got Giannis a
two-time MVP and Chris Middleton he only
played 50 games last year and Holiday
to me those are the two most attractive
spots if you're a head coach why did Doc
Rivers get fired
look I'm gonna try to be positive here
Theodore
but look
unfortunately
players have guaranteed contracts and
the coaches will always be the first to
go let me first start by saying that
coaches are always first to go but but
man these players gotta lick themselves
in the mirror that
these guys some of those players on that
team are not going to name names are
pumped
they're pumps come on man
Doc is the Fall Guy
very much the same way Monty Williams to
me was the Fall Guy in Phoenix
these players got to look themselves in
the mirror I'm putting this on the
players I'm sorry if you could if if it
was you could keep James Harden or you
could keep Doc Rivers but you couldn't
keep them both who would you keep
because it feels like that maybe what
this came down to
you keeping James Harden or Doc Rivers
if I'm ownership group yeah
I love me some James Harden first ballot
Hall of Famer do you still love him
I I love him but I'm but I'm keeping doc
real okay
hey I agree I agree first battle Hall of
Famer and I have enjoyed watching him
but I would say James thank you some
nice parting gifts here and it's not
guaranteed that James is going to stay
there no no you got rid of Doc yeah you
got rid of Doc and and James Harden
still can lead
yeah but they got to turn this over to
Tyrese Maxie and and Joe lmb though they
have to be the two-headed monster in
there that you know moving forward all
right uh I'm running out of time but I
want to get your take if I said to you
John Morant wants to sit down and talk
what would you talk to John morent about
right now
and nobody's going to hear you this
isn't on camera this is you and and
you're going to give him advice what
would you say to him
uh
I want you to look at your inner circle
and I want you to write a list down of
all your boys all your homies right and
I want to look at them all and I want to
say I want you to burn it up right now
you've got a clean house young man
and look
the people that he has surrounded
himself with
and some of this could be family
involved as well
you've got to look at the whole picture
my friend
and what you have and what you can
achieve
and right now what's being taken away
from you
which life do you want to live
but reg you played with guys
who you probably had conversations with
that they were doing stupid things and
that didn't mean they stopped doing
stupid things
and look at them now
there's cautionary tales all throughout
this league
there really is
you know I can give you a handful of
guys that I've played with or you've
seen on other teams that have gone down
this route where are they today John
Morant
before all this was being painted as one
of the faces of the new league yeah of
these new up-and-coming young players
and now he's being vilified to his own
doing
you're right this is not us catching him
doing something this is him doing it on
his own phone he's self-induced all this
yeah
and it felt like the commissioner that
this hurt him personally yeah because
you know what you we had a face to face
we sat down and we locked eyes and I
felt that we were on the same page
because the commissioner only wants
success for the Memphis Grizzlies and
John and he felt the worst coming out of
jaw's mouth and he believed him and the
old phrase bamboozle Hoodwink let us
straight
that's how the commissioner feels and he
feels embarrassed that's why it'll
probably be a heavy suspension coming
the start of next season but could you
imagine David Stern's approach as
opposed oh Adam Silverman he's lucky
David Stern isn't a hold of this he's so
lucky David Stern is not at the ham of
this yeah he would have been given the
wrong or he's been gone
you've been given the Ron or test
treatment which was unfair and unjust
let me just say that for the brawl but
he would have been given that type of
treatment
yeah I always thought wrong like maybe I
misread his personality but Ron Artest
seemed like he was a kid like he was fun
and what happened in Detroit
like just that moment set him off but
you were there with him all the time
like how would you describe his
personality he would have his moments
where he would come in and out
um but I felt I could always rein him in
at times and and showed him and told him
the big picture of things about winning
and once he could focus in on just
winning as opposed to I'm not getting
this and I I I and I can get him to
focus on the wee wee wee he understood
that and I'm glad he turned things
around and he got a chance with the
Lakers to win a championship and I hope
some of those lessons that in those
conversations we had in the locker room
on the plane rides
um I think he he understood the emphasis
on we as opposed to the eye and these
kids come in you know John thinks he
knows everything at 23. I keep not going
to listen to you he'd be like yeah
whatever you know you're an old guy man
I I got to do what I got to do man
that's why old heads are so important on
championship teams all right Al Horford
that's why his presence is needed for
the Celtics Haslam that's why his
presence is valuable for the Miami Heat
uh DeAndre Jordan for Denver and LeBron
for the Lakers you've got to have old
heads guys that have seen and done smelt
touched everything hey by the way you
get a chance to talk about Al Horford
future Hall of Famer tonight
are you happy about that because after
that last game when he was home
we were texting during the game he might
get a triple single tonight reg I'm just
saying you might've got the triple
single gold
I think Al may give me seven points six
rebounds four assists two blocks Hall of
Fame that's good but that's good yeah
that's pretty good yeah you know yeah
they're doing all the heavy lifting
yeah
have fun tonight have fun tonight
Reggie Miller Hall of Famer be on the
call tonight Boston game one 8 30
Eastern on TNT